[Music]
I'm working for somebody leads you know
ready to go George is my name and you
I'm sorry we should set off what we we
don't have time
okay Bobo wants a dinner at the straight
[Music]
and in here repeat sample project
earlier they could do plantation for
maize which means will become they would
support the project so you plant some
maize and remeasure
to support the project
wretches enormous
[Music]
yeah it's still great eager Samuel if
you just jump straight off the plane go
missing the plots of land some of the
Landers to sail and some of it the
owners have said that they'll give us
the land on the condition that we be
able to school on air and we do XY and Z
so we're just really trying to wire up
our options why don't we do way up you
can open it so peaceful here I can't
imagine don't have in school here
because no one around although they're
saying they'll give us the land for free
too if we've all the school on it
there's probably no plug building unless
it's in them in my area so we're
thinking a lot about sustainability
you know how I'm gonna you know
potential you might have like a some
agriculture on the lands whereby they
can you know grow crops and sell them
which then funds it so there's just so
much to think about
but the reason we want to go to school
is because education is absolutely
everything and if people know how to be
entrepreneurs and know how to make money
then what happens is you make money from
being valuable and by being valuable
more people that are valuable to a
society that's what really relieves
poverty so I mean Uganda's a very rich
place there's a lot of resources but
there's also lots there is a lot of
poverty as people with nothing and I
think that with good schools good
education and then abilities available
to make money and add value I really
really truly believe that that is being
moved to the problem so rather than just
trying to
let's say that they don't give a give a
man a fish teach a man to fish and in
the same way rather than trying to look
at the fruit and say why is they know
for it you won't always get to the room
and I think education is deal with the
problem is teaching people how to how to
think so that's why we're really going
down to education Britain in the past
we've done things like we've built we
built what Wells and water things and
we've brought food and water where we've
been fixing the immediate problem but I
really want to make an impact and in
something even bigger than that
something that's gonna be able to go on
for generations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're hearing ginger and there's a
secondary school which is fantastic when
you probably hear the kids and there's
desperate need of a primary school so at
the moment all the really young kids we
meet just right here but it's not really
a proper building and it's very very
very small potentially what we could do
is build a primary school on this one
here that might be Albert old maybe
around about 100 children really nice
location there's a lot of families all
around so we'll see what happens
[Applause]
[Music]
so basically this school that we're at
was this this was built by the parents
of the village of the other village kids
and there's over 400 kids that come to
this school but it's you know it's
basically falling down there's no
infrastructure there's no water the
nearest water from here is a kilometer
away there's no electricity so it's
really difficult to teach the kids
properly with such little resources so
what they're trying to do at the moment
is they're trying to get the council to
give them a grant to just knock the
whole thing down and build it properly
from scratch and also install some water
supplies but they've been trying to do
that for years realistically it's never
it's never gonna happen I'm tempted to
just say well funder will do it but
obviously I don't speak too soon because
there's just so many different things
that you can do it's just working out
what the best thing to do is but really
like this village and it's Ryle of that
what they're doing in the fact of that
despite they've got no resources all
have any resources they're making their
best and the kids are still all coming
together and now learning but I think
with just a little bit of money spent on
the proper building it could be massive
and so you transform the village
[Music]
so we're at Nabi O'Toole school it's a
fantastic school although there's a few
walls missing but that's okay
it doesn't stop these guys because
they're very hard workers we've got some
very smart students I believe are you
smart students are you smart students
that's good say bye to the camera are
you a teacher here yeah okay how long
videos three years what's the biggest
need in Uganda it rains an awful lot
which means that like now there's a
thunderstorm come in so with no wolves
on a classroom if it rains you just
can't study so it's really important
that we have proper infrastructure on
the classrooms so that these guys can
study better
rather than necessarily building the
school from scratch in light make sense
finding the school that's already
existing that can't function properly
and then helping help him put back
making that better and putting it right
so that the kids can then Gallimore done
[Applause]
believe it or not there is currently a
school so what happens is every day kids
come and they all sit under this tree
and teachers come and teach them and
they use this as a school so Wow fair
enough
and there's like crops where you can
grow things nice place good energy no
building see that's the thing a school
is not a building of scores of the
people there's another another school
over here another classroom how crazy is
it that you can have a school we've not
even an attempt of making the building
just nothing by building at all there's
no food there's no water there's no
electric there's no building there's
just there's no desks there's no
computers there's just absolutely no I
think so you are very limited in your
ability to be able to you know your
potential is capped Braille a because
there's some kids in this school that
are really really smart without the
resources you just can't get to
come on the ridges between you they
would you never one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we've spent the last two days looking
at those different sites planks farm
schools of where we could potentially
build a school where we are right now is
very very wrong there's no schools
nearby
there's a lot of kids and I think this I
think this could be I think this could
be where we're going to do it because
there's so much maize and agriculture
and there's chickens and the kids are
gathering at the moment they're
gathering here but just with no school
and that they're learning and everyone's
trying to chip in and do their best but
there's just no school some of the other
places that we've been to there are
decent schools around already whereas
here there's just nothing and the kids
that we're talking to like that the kids
that were set down studying half of them
haven't eaten anything today and won't
be anything and it's just like you know
it's just it's just there's so much need
I think we'd have greatest impact here
so from all the places that we've seen
this is where I'm I'm most drawn to I
think at the moment I've no idea how
much this is gonna cost like absolutely
no idea building a school and everything
they might go with that but we'll figure
that out
get out later
[Music]
I was gonna fall in land we're gonna
find opportunity to better build a
school that's not been the problem if I
have had the opposite problem we found
so many opportunities to build schools
we found so much land we have so many
people offering to give us land on the
condition that would be on school there
are so many government schools and
councils were going to partner with us
it's just been opportunity after
opportunity
well the best barbecue man organic beef
chicken chicken livers smells so good
I was hungry until I got here and now
this is the best thing about Uganda
apart from the people every doctor that
I saw in the UK because I went to many
hospitals every single one of them said
whoever did the operation knew what they
were doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well it was every time I thought may
even be was just one pounds I would
separate it freed up and then with 10%
into savings certificate to church 10
who said I would use on something that I
want it may need to go out for a drink
of some friends 10% I would use took my
education 10% our journey metal phones
[Music]
[Music]
so pretty well so just had a long
meeting with the head of all the schools
around this part of Uganda and I told
them that I think we should introduce
business and finance education in the
schools and surprisingly they were
really open to it and they basically
said sure let's do it
so I think that now it's a it's on me to
come up with a clear proposal they've
given me the authority and permission to
go and teach in the schools myself and
also to bring people from the UK or
whoever teach people they've also
offered me opportunities to meet with
for them to bring all the teachers of
all the schools together and do a
workshop with the teachers so the doors
open really it's just a case of figuring
out how to how to scale this and make
sure that it really happens and how to
implement it properly but big massive
challenge but I'm excited so we're in
the mountains right now and it is
absolutely freezing about to go to a
village where we install the water tanks
and it's a bit hilly I think Amanda's
shoes are gonna get absolutely destroyed
so if I'm speaking from previous
experience because last time my shoes
got with care I destroyed those shoes
you'll never wear them again
[Music]
how are you shoes not bad I mean could
be worse could be way worse yeah it's
like you were flying or what those no I
took careful footsteps how's the climb
victim I would you like to live in a
condition like that no sorry
I'm African but lives in an area like
this is to be heard from the impact that
the talk have done to us is like now
when talk of libera libera has been
reduced a bit you know when going down
to to look for Jay can I get a jig and
and I get like a Jake on top of you or
your head
caring ultra narrator's has been at
least we just a bit not Poconos we get
closer to the tank and then it comes
easy and first their families has also
helped us to get clean water because
this were tides from the Luffy is very
clean then I think the water from the
lake because the water from the lake
kids from different inlets and we may
not expect the well that's mattered this
water from the laughing yeah that's the
joy can you use so when you're looking
for water may be going down by the lake
you must have got this there's a
generator the Jerry can and you can
color on the top to get down by the lake
to your home and for me when I where I
live is over like a but maybe like about
seven to eight kilometers I think I were
from the lake so which means is going to
be tiresome for me when I'm going down
by the lake not to get to water then
it's not just eight kilometres straight
we're about to the top of the hill so
it's very hard most of the time to come
down and come up with a container of the
check when you get enough water from the
tank we make bricks from it and canals
of course a kind of an air pass to beat
budahas also we can sell of the the
bricks after making them from the water
this village they have over about 40
people and then the others which is
about 15 about their arm on the top of
the hill so we have over a current
people that use the two tank sofa at
least it would be like maybe two or
three families right we won
and sherry I would be very very much
nicer than you know sharing thunk of
like 40 people so you can use water in a
few days they were ties oh she is
finished in attack five thousand liters
but that should be the side of the time
we have water is right
and what Samuel has read has brought to
the village has definitely changed many
lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]